protagonismo latinoamericano en esta
competencia en Estados Unidos Valentina
Obregón está haciendo sin duda el
mundial de atletismo de Perú lamarchista
Kimberly García se convirtió este
viernes en la única atleta en completar
un doblete de oros allá en ese torneo se
había proclamado campeón en los 20 km y
repitió en los 35 kilómetros marcha
conectamos en este momento con nuestro
enviado especial a Eugene Oregón Juan
José sayago Juan son dos oros
consagratorios para un atleta con
muchísima experiencia
sí sobre todo tomando en cuenta Juan que
después del resultado de Tokio quiso
retirarse Kimberly García de practicar
la marcha atlética y aquí se ha
convertido en doble campeona mundial es
la primera latinoamericana en toda la
historia en conseguir Dos Oros en un
mismo Campeonato del mundo lo ha
conseguido aquí en hollín en Oregón Y de
esta manera pasa la historia como una de
las grandes atletas y representantes de
latinoamérica Cabe destacar que hay una
historia adicional Dentro de este logro
de Kimberly García y es que el día
domingo va a marchar en este escenario
en el mismo sitio El doblete Dorado su
entrenador quien es nada menos que
Andrés un grandísimo marchista
ecuatoriano Pero qué nos dijo que
inverti García lo vemos a continuación
estoy muy contenta de haber logrado
estas dos medallas como dije la verdad
no esperábamos
ganarme desde oro Sí ubicarnos en un
buen lugar pero claro con la comisión de
que en cada competencia venimos a
pelearnos pero pero nada este Me he
preparado muchísimo he estado trabajando
muy duro para para lograr esto he sido
mi sueño desde muy pequeña